bonjour à tous
alors
quelle est la probabilité que je sois
aujourd'hui ici avec vous vous
ensemble
à Toulouse
pour répondre à cette question là je
vais vous donner
quelques informations
je viens dans tout petit peu
4 millions d'habitants presque comme des
koalas en voie d'extension
un million est parti à l'étranger à
cause de la situation économique
j'ai bien d'une famille modeste dans
lesquelles il y avait trois garçons je
suis l'unique fille et on Nicaragua les
garçons font des études
ils sont plutôt privilégiés par les
familles pour faire des études plus que
les filles c'est pas une raison
culturelle ni un problème religieux
c'est un problème économique alors vous
comprenez que mon destin était scellé de
tout le début
mais j'ai rencontré des gens extrêmement
bienveillantes depuis ma naissance
malgré un parcours dans lesquels il y a
eu des tremblements de terre la guerre
des situations très difficiles dans mon
pays mais j'étais toujours accompagnée
par des personnes qui voulaient m'aider
à aller au-delà et j'ai profité
aujourd'hui
pour
faire un match à mon grand-père les
dernières chefs détrives indiens Nawal
en Amérique centrale qui m'a donné
l'envie de vivre un harmonie avec la
nature mais aussi il m'a transmis toute
une quantité des connaissances sur les
végétaux les coections la santé mais il
y a quelque chose qui m'a apporté qui
était extrêmement important pour moi
c'était pensé à l'autre c'est lui qui
est à côté de nous même si c'est un
inconnu on a une capacité chacun de nous
de donner et de aussi et de l'autre
cette compassion cette bienveillance
cette bonté est possible à faire tous
les jours à notre niveau à notre échelle
dans notre quotidien
et donc cette immense quantité de
personnes qui m'ont construit et qui
m'ont transmis leur expérience et leur
bonté et leur aide m'ont permis de
sortir de ce qui était ma destinée j'ai
fait des études à l'école et j'apprenais
vite on sait pas comment ça fonctionne
mais c'était comme ça et j'ai
fait des échelons en après les autres et
je suis devenue au début champion des
mathématiques dans mon petit village
champion de mathématiques dans ma ville
et après champion des mathématiques on
Nicaragua et cette envie d'apprendre
c'est quelque chose qui m'a pris au
tripes depuis que j'étais toute petite
j'ai fait ça le ménage à la bibliothèque
pour pouvoir emprunter des livres dans
mon village et pouvoir lire comprendre à
12 ans j'avais lu déjà quelques pages de
Tolstoï il appelle la guerre c'était
quelque chose une découverte magnifique
qui me permettait de rêver de me dire
dès que il y avait une autre façon de
faire et que peut-être il avait une
autre à venir
alors
je me suis dit que tout était possible
et
quand j'avais gagné cette concours des
mathématiques en Amérique centrale
ça m'a permis ça m'a ouvert une grande
porte pour pouvoir faire des études
supérieures
et à 18 ans avec 20 dollars dans la
poche une valisette et une veste en jean
ça c'est très important je suis parti en
Moscou affronter les froids
et c'était une expérience fabuleuse j'ai
rentré dans une Institute où il avait 14
nationalités différentes il a fallu
s'adapter je venais dans toute petit
pays comme la Nicaragua et donc il a
fallu apprendre les mathématiques un
niveau beaucoup plus important de ce que
je savais les langues l'économie et
c'était formidable c'était un champ de
jeux pour moi fabuleux j'allais
apprendre à prendre et c'est comme ça
que j'ai passé 10 années à Moscou j'ai
fini un master en économie
internationale avec connaissance des
langues et
Moscou
toute cette à Moscou tout cette relation
que j'ai eu avec tout cette nationalité
qui m'ont beaucoup apporté ils m'ont
enrichi ils m'ont fait comprendre que
des fois la raison et chez l'autre et
pas chez soi
ça m'a permis aussi de comprendre la
différence culturelle qu'on peut avoir
tous mais une chose que j'ai remarqué
c'est qu'on avait tous les mêmes rêves
on voulait tous être heureux peu importe
du monde et donc ça a forgé aussi mon
caractère
et après je suis arrivée en France par
une décision personnelle
et un 2011 j'ai eu un cancer de la
thyroïde
j'avais fait un passage auparavant au
Brésil et j'avais travaillé dans des
associations avec des enfants
mais qu'on a mal à redit arrive chez
vous étape à la porte pour quelqu'un qui
n'avait même pas eu un rhume d'habitude
j'étais super romain c'est pas possible
que j'aille quelque chose et ben non ça
m'est arrivé aussi à moi
[Musique]
elle est plus dur dans les cancers
c'est pas que vous êtes malade bien sûr
vous avez très peur mais ce qui est dur
c'est que vous ne pouvez pas faire rien
d'autre
pour ceux qui sont malades pour vos
proches et donc souvent les aidants ils
sont dans une situation dans lesquelles
ils peuvent juste être là et c'est déjà
formidable qu'ils sont là et donc une de
mes amis a eu un cancer du sein à ce
moment-là mais une autre et une autre
ont eu aussi des cancers du sein et donc
je me suis retrouvée avec un entourage
dans lesquels mes copines avaient des
cancers du sein un peu c'était un peu
partout dans le monde aux États-Unis en
Russie et en France
et une de mes amis qui avait un cancer
du sein avait des maux de dos très
importantes
80% des femmes qui portent des prothèses
externes souffrent des maux de dos ce
n'est pas seulement à cause de la du
porte des prothèses mais c'est aussi une
cause importante l'effet de pas être
appareillé comme il fallait et donc avec
cet ami
elle m'a expliqué elle m'a dit Léonard
d'abricole moi quelque chose ça commence
c'est comme ça sauf que moi je viens pas
du monde médical je n'ai aucune batte
grande médicale donc il a fallu se
plonger à apprendre encore pour pouvoir
comprendre déjà qu'est-ce que c'est une
prothèse et donc tout est passé dedans
les règlements de terre la chimie
la création elle-même et c'est comme ça
qui est né l'idée de créer des prothèses
mammaires externes personnalisées et se
remet sur
pourquoi parce que pour moi aider les
femmes étaient quelque chose de
primordial essayez de transformer la vie
de ceux qui sont dans une douleur
intense les cancers du sein bien sûr que
c'est un cancer qui juste les mots
cancer ça fait peur mais elle a un
impact dans la féminité des femmes et
c'est souvent très dur à démarrer et à
reprendre la vie les cours normal de la
vie
donc je me suis posée la question
comment je pouvais faire quelque chose
de nouveau et vous voyez c'est là que
pour moi est important un élément
innovation on innove pas pour créer
quelque chose on innove pas juste pour
une nouveauté nous sommes responsables
de ce qui nous sommes en train de créer
et l'impact que nous allons avoir vers
l'environnement vers les patientes qui
sont besoin mais aussi vers notre
société
donc j'ai je me suis plongée dans
différentes types
des métiers pour pouvoir comprendre
comment on fait ça une prothèse c'était
la base de la base
et donc aujourd'hui mon objectif c'est
que les patientes quand elle porte une
prothèse elle puisse reprendre leur
cours de la vie avec un produit qui soit
ergonomique mais aussi esthétique et
c'est important penser que l'innovation
nous sommes chacun de nous responsable
de ce que nous sommes en train de créer
quel impact nous allons avoir dans la
société quel impact nous allons avoir
dans l'environnement c'est notre
responsabilité aujourd'hui on a assez
des informations partout dans lesquelles
on peut plus continuer à dire on va
produire sans être capable de gérer ce
que nous produisons et ce que nous
sommes en train de créer
donc comme vous comprendrez une prothèse
c'est un dispositif médical donc c'est
quelque chose que j'ai découvert il y a
10 ans
alors chaque année il y a 58 000
nouveaux cas des cancers en France et il
y a 20 000 nouvelles femmes qui font une
mastectomie et 150 000 femmes en France
utilisent des prothèses externes
donc on rajoute de la douleur à la
douleur quand une prothèse ne correspond
pas on n'est pas ergonomique pour une
patiente mais il faut pas oublier les
hommes
oui pour cent vous monsieur
c'est important aussi prendre conscience
des chiffres parce que 8% des hommes
souffrent d'un cancer aussi du sang
alors moi j'ai créé une prothèse
ergonomique qui donne les sourires aux
femmes et qui puisse les faire sentir en
confiance
l'effet de créer des prothèses
ça m'est venu cette idée
comme une évidence parce que aujourd'hui
on prend pas en compte la beauté
esthétique de ces comportes sauf que
pour une femme c'est une vraie
propulation de son image et cette image
là elle est très importante parce que ça
les permet de sortir de la maladie je
suis convaincue que quand on est
passionné pour ce qu'on fait on peut
transmettre cette passion de façon
différente et si je suis venu
aujourd'hui si je suis si j'ai accepté
de venir à tête x aujourd'hui c'est
parce que si je peux un tout petit peu
vous semblant c'est à suivre vos rêves
peu importe l'âge qu'on a il tient pas
de temps dash il n'y a pas de diplôme
chacun de nous peut se passionner pour
ce qu'il aime et chacun de nous peut
aussi innover nos prothèses sont non
seulement une innovation technologique
parce que on crée d'une façon
complètement différente on utilise les
dernières technologies la les 3D
l'intelligence artificielle pour faire
nos calculs mais vous voyez tout ça
c'est de la science et après il y a
l'homme et la femme veut dire notre
capacité aussi dépenser que la
bienveillance est ce que nous on est en
train de faire peu avant un impact dans
la vie de l'autre donc c'est pour ça que
j'ai su arriver à développer cette
projet aujourd'hui on est commercialisé
c'est des prothèses que c'est
commercialise mais bien sûr entraînement
de l'idée et là le moment de la création
d'une prothèse qui répondent à toute la
réglementation il y a cette cheminement
de l'innovation cette cheminement qui
s'est fait petit à petit pas à pas
et il y a bien sûr une charge de travail
importante pour pouvoir arriver
à atteindre ses rêves
donc je me suis dit que c'était
important peut-être pour chaque
rendez-vous
qui porte aujourd'hui une
une idée une envie que vous sachez que
il n'y a rien qui peut vous arrêter le
nid chose qui peut vous arrêter c'est
votre propre limite que vous vous donnez
mais sinon vous pouvez attendre tout ce
que vous souhaitez et dans les mondes du
cancer du sein c'est que c'est important
à comprendre c'est que aussi
on peut aider des façons différentes
et je voulais vous proposer aujourd'hui
un exercice
mais on doit les faire tous ensemble je
vais vous je vais vous proposer de faire
un geste d'amour
défaire un dépistage collectif
aujourd'hui quand vous avez compris
je porte mon sac à dos rose tous les
jours c'est mon métier j'ai décidé qu'il
soit ça et pour rien au monde j'ai
changerai de faire des prothèses parce
que je vais à la rencontre des femmes
qui sont des grands sourires et je peux
vous dire que c'est tellement gratifiant
avoir un métier dans lequel vous savez
que vous pouvez aider les autres
alors comme aujourd'hui c'est les
premières octobre c'est les mois du
dépistage contre les cancers du sein je
vous invite à apprendre à faire les
gestes pour faire un dépistage et bien
sûr que on a très peur qu'on fait un
dépistage mais faire un dépistage c'est
un geste d'amour à la vie ça peut vous
sauver à vous ça peut sauver vos proches
toutes les femmes de votre entourage et
ça permet surtout de vivre donc je vous
invite à vous lever
tous
on lève la main
d'un côté
l'autre main on peut on va aller
chercher nos ganglions
[Musique]
cette partie là avec la main opposée on
cherche
et même si on trouve quelque chose
sachez que nous vivons en France et que
la France a une qualité de soins
incroyables on tourne autour de notre
sang les hommes des hommes torse
ça s'appelle en français voilà on
cherche
et vous voyez cette geste là que vous
êtes en train de faire ça sauve toutes
les femmes si vous en parlez il faut
apprendre à comprendre
finaliser et on fait l'autre côté parce
qu'on a deux bras
donc vous comprenez que je compte sur
chacun de vous vous êtes potentiellement
des sauveurs de vie
je compte sur chacun des vous pour que
vous parlez autour de vous qu'il
dépistage c'est très important et vous
tournez autour de votre sang voilà
je vous remercie infiniment de vous
avoir prêté dans cette exercice que
c'est pas facile
merci
alors mes chers sauveurs de vie Manon
vous savez les gestes qu'il faut
transmettre
et je vous pose de nouveau la question
quelle est la probabilité
dès qu'on soit aujourd'hui
chacun de nous ensemble à parler
d'innovation sur Toulouse
je vous laisse répondre par vous-même
merci